need all the strength and care possible
for them to be okay we're thinking about
the families who lost a loved one
yesterday or who have a family member
here at one of the hospitals but I'm
also thinking about the wife of one of
the patients I met yesterday whose
husband was shot in the chest who had
not yet been conscious enough to connect
with his family and she didn't know how
he was going to do and asked me in the
midst of all that why does this keep
happening and what are we going to do as
a country to stop that from happening
and she asked me that over and over
again and in addition to finding the the
resolve and the will to pass universal
background checks to close the loopholes
to stop selling these weapons of war
into our communities we also have to
address the the racism the intolerance
the anti-immigrant rhetoric that that
very well may be in part the cause of
the shooting that we saw yesterday of
shootings that we see in in different
parts of the country violence that if we
do not confront it will be the new
normal in this country a rise in hate
crimes every single one of the last
three years only getting worse not
getting better until all of us stand up
to be counted against this and for
something far better for for this
country and I'm confident El Paso is
going to have a leading role given what
we just experienced I think that's what
changes for this community we now
unfortunately have this experience can
speak from this perspective and and I
hope during that urgency to this issue
so that we change it what's that we
reached out to the Mexican president yet
I spoke to the Consul General of Mexico
yesterday last night in fact at
University Medical Center as we were
meeting with the families and the
parents and the sons and daughters of
the victims were being treated there he
said the government of Mexico is doing
everything that they can and offered his
help going forward